Israel has announced that it signed a
directive officially allowing Israelis
to visit Saudi Arabia for religious or
business trips
Saudi Arabia doesn't have diplomatic
relations with Israel and doesn't allow
Israeli passport carriers to visit
except for most Muslim pilgrimage the
announcement comes just days before US
President Donald Trump said that he
would release his much touted Middle
East peace plan let's go live now to
West Jerusalem Al Jazeera's Harry faucet
sir can tell us more about this Harry
well yes in some respects this is a
formalization of something that has been
growing in recent years and especially
in recent months in terms of the
business ties between Israel and Saudi
Arabia the generally warming
relationship Palestinian Israelis have
gone in groups to perform the the Hajj
pilgrimage as well but all of this has
been done in a pretty clandestine or at
least not officially approved way this
make no mistake is a very major shift in
the public nature of the relationship
between Israel and Saudi Arabia now
Israeli citizens will be able to travel
with official invitations from Saudi
officials not just for religious reasons
but also for business visits the Israeli
interior ministry saying that Israelis
will be able to seek investment
opportunities inside Saudi Arabia and
that as long as they have a visa and an
official invitation they will get exit
permits from Israel lasting up to 90
days so this is a real show of the
warming relationship between these two
countries which has long been talked
about but this is a very public
pronouncement of it it's also something
of a challenge to Saudi Arabia's stance
when it comes to normalizing relations
with Israel it is of course a signatory
to the Arab Peace Initiative which
allows for normalization between Israel
and Arab neighbors only once the
Palestinian issue has been settled with
conditions such as Israel pulling out of
the occupied territories and Palestinian
sovereignty in East Jerusalem none of
those things obviously have happened and
the timing of this
just as both Benny Gant's the leader of
Israel's opposition in the largest party
and the Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu were both on their way to
Washington DC for separate meetings with
Donald Trump ahead of the rollout of the
Trump peace plan big event on Tuesday
between Trump and Netanyahu and all the
indications from the leaks are that this
will be a plan which really blows
through all sorts of palestinian red
lines in terms of Palestinian demands of
what should come of any resolution to
the israeli-palestinian conflict this
will be a test for the Saudi position
and there will be a further test when it
is officially unveiled as to how the
Saudi Arabians and other Arab nations
react so far there's been no direct
reaction to this announcement from the
Palestinians but the Palestinian foreign
minister did say that Trump would not
find any Palestinian or Arab who'd
approve of the deal of the century which
is likely to be unveiled as I say later
this week question is how strong the
disapproval might be how it will be
expressed the indications from this deal
between Israel and Saudi Arabia or this
announcement from Israel at least is
that the relationship is growing and at
the time just before these very
consequential events could start to get
underway in Washington Al Jazeera's
Harry faucet reporting live from West
Jerusalem many thanks indeed Harry